good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight happy wednesday we want
to take you back a couple of februaries
ago not that long but really a different
time
february 2019 an american c-17 cargo jet
takes off from an air force base in
florida it's bound for south america the
media are covering this it's a big story
that day inside the plane pallets of
wheelchairs and crutches these are gifts
from the people of the united states to
the long oppressed population of
venezuela venezuela venezuela's
socialist economy famously had collapsed
utterly by that point there was no
toilet paper in caracas people were
eating zoo animals to stay alive the
average venezuelan had lost more than 10
pounds from starvation
so the point of sending humanitarian aid
to venezuela was to show the world that
americans are decent but more than that
that the american system works this
country is so rich that we can afford to
send crutches and wheelchairs to our
enemies
again that was 2019 it wasn't the berlin
airlift it was the other day
but a lot has changed we're not shipping
any more crutches or wheelchairs to
venezuela or anywhere else for that
matter and we're not because we don't
have enough for ourselves
less than a year into the joe biden
administration the united states faces
massive and potentially dangerous
shortages of just about everything
just this week one of the largest
healthcare providers in the western
united states it's called intermountain
healthcare began soliciting help from
its own patients
according to a local news report
officials at intermountain healthcare
were urging people to quote check their
closets attics and garages for used
metal crutches and other walk-assist
equipment
dr joseph camarath runs intermountain's
physical rehab operation in the state of
utah i've never seen this he said i've
practiced healthcare in various
continents i recently moved from the
middle east every time i come back to
practice healthcare in north america i'm
so grateful for our supply chain that we
take for granted
and now all of a sudden we can see that
we can't order anymore
can't order anymore not a small thing
when you run a hospital
multiply that story
times an entire continent and you begin
to understand the current state of the
american economy hospitals begging for
medical equipment
essential goods unavailable everywhere
supply chains frozen just months before
christmas
it's not improving it could get much
worse very quickly here's a snapshot of
where we are tonight
the supply chain issue could be hitting
your thanksgiving table this year
grocery stores are warning that they're
expecting a shortage of turkeys stores
are starting to see shortages of items
such as pet food frozen food and diapers
doug fabioli has spent nearly two
decades in loudoun county as a wine
maker but a lack of bottles nationwide
could put his supply at risk a shortage
of ketchup is impacting restaurants
around the country quantities of single
serve packets have dwindled during the
pandemic leaving the tomato based paste
in short supply but there are certainly
shortages of everything from bread to
potato chips
and even toilet paper suddenly you just
can't buy the stuff you want
book publishers are having trouble
getting paper car companies can't buy
computer chips
builders are having trouble getting
lumber
container ships in port are waiting for
days to be unloaded
yeah it's everything
diapers pet food ketchup bread
etc etc etc
now the ports particularly the port of
long beach ports on the west coast have
gotten a lot of attention recently but
the problem is bigger than that it's not
just crowded ports the problems begin
thousands of miles away over the past
year the average time it takes for a
container to reach the united states
from across the pacific from asia has
jumped by nearly 50 percent it was 51
days now it's 74 days that's unlikely to
change any time soon among other things
that means that most of what you buy in
the store or order online is about to
become much more expensive
as fox's william martinez reported
recently so much of our retail economy
now depends on the cost of shipping
goods from china
a record 159 ships 63 in port but 96
offshore waiting sometimes weeks to dock
longshoremen say they're ready to heed
the president's call for 24 7 but when
the ports asked truckers to work the
three to seven am shift not enough
showed we have three shifts first second
and third
they choose not to work the third
because there's no one comes to pick up
the cargo in the third shift because on
the other side of the supply chain there
is no place to take the container cost
of a shipping container from china to la
is 16 000 up 330 percent from a year ago
and once here the trucking rate per mile
is up 23 percent not including fuel
so trucking costs just one link in a
very long and quite complex chain
trucking costs up nearly 25 not
including fuel
but of course in real life we do include
fuel fuel is one of the biggest expenses
for americans who don't live in the
urban core that's most people according
to aaa the average price of gasoline per
gallon is now 3.30 so to refresh your
memory just a year ago it was about two
bucks
now this country has immense energy
reserves up until recently we bragged
about being quote energy independent
that was going to free us from our
dependence on the middle east and all
those pointless wars that killed so many
americans and drained our treasury we
are proud of that
how do we get energy shortages in a
country that has more energy than it can
consume
well that was not accidental it was
entirely intentional it was the result
of policies that came from washington
and maybe that's why joe biden does not
seem upset about it when asked
now cars may be a threat to the global
climate but more pressing cars equal
physical autonomy they're yours you can
take them where you want and by this
point we know very well where this
administration stands on the question of
physical autonomy so watch joe biden as
he's asked about this
do you have a timeline for gas prices of
when you think they may start coming
down
my guess is you'll start to see gas
prices come down as we get by and going
into the winter i mean excuse me in the
next year in 2022 i don't see anything
that's going to happen in the meantime
it's going to significantly reduce gas
prices i don't have a near near-term
answer
gas prices
that's not some kind of esoteric
question
again for most people who don't work at
non-profits in washington or have
signing cures at mckinsey gas prices are
essential
they determine how much money you have
day to day
and yet biden's response the most blase
imaginable i don't have a near-term
answer
i don't have a near-term answer
but that's not always his answer it
really depends upon what the question is
so for example the administration felt
that it had to import thousands of
unvetted unvaccinated afghan refugees
biden did have a short-term answer in
fact he described it as a national
emergency it couldn't wait not one
moment
and so the biden white house mobilized
the entire u.s government to get those
people into your neighborhood that was
very important to them
but your household budget how much money
you have whether you can take your kids
out for dinner
who cares
deal with it legacy american you have no
right to expect more
that's their position
so say goodbye to cheap gasoline
probably forever that was the basis upon
which
our modern society was structured that's
why we have suburbs that by the way the
administration hates what most people
enjoy living in
can't live in suburbs with gasoline that
you can't afford and it's not just
gasoline heating oil too and jet fuel
and natural gas and all the other
immoral hydrocarbons
cheap fuel is over in this country and
it's intentional permanent shortages
ahead
and by the way such as fuel go ahead and
try and build something right now we
dare you
the following construction materials
have now been listed as quote delayed
meaning very tough to get they include
adhesives appliances copper drywall
electrical equipment fabricated metals
furniture hvac equipment lumber pvc pipe
steel and so on essentially pretty much
everything
good luck fixing your house
or for that matter filling your fridge
many common goods the ones you bought in
the grocery store last year without
thinking about are now effectively
luxury items
the statistics are staggering showing
food prices rose 4.6 percent this year
compared to last year and when it's
broken down to specific food items the
numbers are even higher with dramatic
increases in meat poultry fish and eggs
ringing in at almost 10.5 percent more
so what's going on here
we'll be honest joe biden didn't do all
of this a lot of things are going on
here and they're happening all at once
the main driver of this is that over
time we have become completely through
various administrations both parties we
become completely dependent on china the
chinese chinese communist party
effectively is our new opec with the
word they can shut down our economy
at the same time the audio logs in the
white house are raising energy costs
just in case you thought maybe we could
make up some of the gap with domestic
manufacturing that's impossible with
energy costs this high you need cheap
energy in order to have a manufacturing
economy period ask anyone in the
business
and then to add to this there is a labor
shortage once again the result of
long-term sad trends
but that has been dramatically
exacerbated by policies from the biden
white house and that labor shortage is
hitting paradoxically at exactly the
moment when there's an unemployment
crisis
that is bizarre and it's scary
take a look at this one measure this is
the labor force participation rate
tonight it's 61.6 percent now what does
that mean for perspective in the middle
of the 2008 meltdown
when we felt the foundation shaking and
people thought the entire u.s economy
was going to crater the labor force
participation rate was five points
higher than it is today
and then look closer at the numbers
something called the prime age male
labor force participation rate which
let's be honest is the essence of this
whole thing now that measure includes
men aged 25 to 54 in what we used to
call the prime of their lives currently
that rate is about 88 percent
what does that mean well for perspective
let's take you back to
1976 which if you were alive and living
in america then you remember as a pretty
grim time economically inflation was
wreaking havoc on the economy we were
worried about energy prices again
even then the labor force participation
for working age males was nowhere near
as low as it is today it was about 94
so to be very clear about these numbers
they have no precedent
right now at exactly the moment when we
need hundreds of
factory workers thousands across the
country you are seeing scenes like this
factory workers walking off the job
well this is certainly no small showing
by members of the local union as well as
other ge employees who say they're not
just frustrated by the vaccine mandate
they also feel betrayed by the company
they say didn't give them enough time to
choose
these factory workers have done a great
job of working through colby and i think
this is just a slap in the face to them
we have been essential for 18 months and
now
we went from heroes to zeros more than
200 schenectady employees walked out on
their general electric jobs in protest
friday
so take three steps back what's going on
here well this administration has
targeted a very specific portion of the
population targeted them for ideological
and political reasons
blue collar men
they're our new kulak class the idea is
they supported the wrong party they have
retrograde attitudes they engage in
wrong think and we're going to crush
them and so systematically they have the
mandates are only one way in which the
bud administration has decided to hurt
this specific group of americans
the problem is and this might not be
evident to the geniuses who work in the
bide administration you can't run a
country without these people they're the
ones who know how to do things
not just report to the hr department but
fix things build things keep the power
grid going fly your airplanes etc etc
etc and it's exactly this group that is
being ground to dust beneath the heel of
the ideologues in the biodemonstration
so what does this mean for you what's
going to have massive ramifications for
your life you can't buy a refrigerator
if there's
no one to build it if there are no
materials to assemble it if there's no
one to put it on a truck and drive it to
your house
so it's a problem for consumer goods but
it's bigger than consumer goods
at some point soon in this continental
country that relies on its vital
transportation grid you may have trouble
getting a flight
southwest airlines we brought you this
story repeatedly is continuing to see
cancelled flights we just got this text
from someone at the company quote
southwest still cancelling or severely
delaying over a thousand flights daily
due to crew non-compliance as an example
this past saturday saw 1352
cancellations or delays in dallas alone
we have over half the baggage handlers
not coming to work
again
these are the people who are being
targeted for pain by the administration
and because no one like this works in
the american media there's not one
person at cnn or msnbc who has any link
to this part of the culture or these
kind of people this story is essentially
going unreported why are things not
working because the people who know how
they work are being fired
or pushed to the point where they're
walking off the job
so here we are at the end of october
think ahead a little bit what's this
going to look like in say six weeks when
the entire united states decides to get
on an airplane and visit their relatives
for the holidays
well we've got tuesday's numbers from
the website flightaware southwest just
named one example had 863 delays that
was the most of any carrier
this is a huge problem and it is almost
certain to get worse
now the white house has been asked about
this about the transportation
stoppages across the country we played
you this tape before we're going to play
it again because it tells you everything
about their attitudes here's joe biden's
chief flack being asked why can't people
buy things in stores anymore here's her
response
people couldn't get dishwashers and and
furniture and treadmills delivered on
time not to mention all sorts of other
things
so why is the tragedy of the short the
treadmill that's delayed
you see the little smirk
that's freshman year dorm room in
oberlin
your treadmill didn't come yeah well
it's not just treadmills it's bread it's
dog food it's ketchup it's building
supplies it's everything it's the flight
to go see my alien grandmother
but these people have no tactile sense
of what the country is like and so
instead of answering these most basic
problems when you're running a country
you care if people can take flights
across it or if they can afford to drive
their own cars or buy ketchup
instead of answering any of these
questions
they're lecturing us about how we should
be delighted that we have a new
four-star trans admiral
that's the prize they're bringing to us
you voted for us here's your trans
admiral be happy
among other things these are totally
unserious people they are purely
ideological they do not care if the
actual country the physical country
comes apart at the seams as long as the
population dutifully repeats the correct
slogans once you understand that you
understand why every day we get some
frivolous new announcement about some
social justice goal that in the end will
not improve the life of a single
american citizen here's today's example
the state department has just announced
it will issue the first passport ever
with an ex-gender marker
huh first of all who cares second why is
the us government trying to pretend that
gender isn't real it's the realest thing
in human society it's the basis of
civilization but whatever
they lectured us today quote this is for
those who don't identify as male or
female
so you won't be able to get on a plane
because no one's working at the airlines
anymore but at least you won't get
misgendered
okay here's another example there's an
ongoing house intel committee hearing
with the heads of the cia nsa and dni
not on how the intel agencies have been
weaponized against american citizens no
that would be too germane that might
actually do something for you if they
stopped reading your texts if that you
post what you wanted on facebook no this
hearing was about dei
that's not a new intel agency
it's a new cult it's called diversity
equity and inclusion so the hearing
began with adam schiff complaining and
this is a key problem for most americans
that all the intel briefers he deals
with
are white men
i can't help but notice that the large
majority of ic briefers though uniformly
excellent who appear before the
committee
are often white and male
we need to recruit officers with diverse
backgrounds into the ic and then we need
to show them that there's a path for
them to advance and grow their careers
to top leadership positions
oh yeah i just can't help notice all my
intel briefers are white men has that
been a problem for you recently as
you're trying to like fix your garage
that's falling down but you can't get
joists is it a problem for you every
time you fill up your truck for three
dollars and 30 cents a gallon
if only we had more diverse intel
briefers this would be a better country
that's what they think that's what
they're spending their time on and
you're paying for it
the white house just issued its first
ever national gender equity and equality
strategy that happened on friday did you
miss it
maybe you were waiting in line trying to
buy food
well one of the highlights from that
plan the white house says it will work
to end cash bail oh that'll make your
life better
but that's not all
the white house also announced it wants
to and we're quoting
seek to eliminate barriers that prevent
immigrants from accessing
government-funded services
oh that's the whole game right there
so you're getting poorer gas prices are
going up we've completely lost control
of the infrastructure in the country
what are the chances we're going to have
blackouts this summer when people dare
to turn on their air conditioning about
100
the white house instead of spending a
single moment trying to fix actual
problems that actually affect your life
has turned the entire force of the
federal government on this question how
can illegal aliens get more free stuff
from the government
that tells you everything
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else